You've got your answers. Let me tell you what
we think the answers are. Now the nice thing
about a decision tree sort of conceptually and intuitively,
is that it really is asking a series of
questions. So, we can simply look at these rows
over here and the values that our features have
and we can just follow down the path of
the tree. So, in the first case. We have true.
We have true for occupied, which means we want to go
down the right side of the tree. And check on the
type. So in the first case, the type is pizza.
And so we go down the first branch and that means.
We do not go down the tree. So, the output is no go.
>> So, okay, so now, I got a different answer. So, I looked at this
and I said happiness is true. And, the bottom box says happiness true, you go.
>> Right. So, you got the wrong, you got what I'm
going to tell you is the wrong answer by going from the
bottom of the tree up. The way decision trees work is
you always start at the root of the tree. That is
the very top of the tree. And you ask the questions in tho, in that order.
>> It just seems like it would be faster to start at the bottom.
>> Yeah but then you would never look at anything else in the tree.
>> Good point. All right so.
>> If you start at the bottom, you can't go up. Alright. So, okay, so let
me see if I get this straight. So I'll, I'll do the, the second instance. The
second instance, you say that we need to start at the top of the tree where
it says occupied. And so now I look
at the instance and the instance says that it's
false for occupied, so we go down that left branch and we hit no
go. Oh wait but now I haven't look at any of the other nodes.
>> You don't have to look at any of the other
nodes because it turns out that if it's not occupied you
just don't go into a restaurant. So you're the type of
person who doesn't like to be the only person in a restaurant.
>> Got it, all right, so that's a no go. So
that's a no-go. That's an important point, Michael. Actually, you might also
notice that this whole tree, even if you look at every single feature in the
tree, only has three of the attributes. It only
looks at occupied. Type. And happiness.
>> I see. So hot date is sort of irrelevant which is good,
because in this case it's not really changing from instance to instance anyway.
>> True. And neither is hungry you might notice.
>> Oh, I am kind of hungry.
>> Although, I'm always hungry. Although raining does in fact change
a little bit here and there. But it apparently it doesn't matter.
>> I see.
>> Because you always take an umbrella.
>> Got it.
>> Okay, so let's quickly do the other three
and see if we we come to the same conclusion.
>> Alright. Well all the instances that have occupied
false we know those are no go, right away.
>> Oh, good point.
>> So we can do it kind of out of order. And
the other ones are both occupied. One is tie and one is other.
For the tie one we go.
The other one, oh I see, for the other
one we have to look at whether there's happiness
or not, and in this instance happiness is true.
So we get on the right branch and we go.
>> And we go. Exactly it. So we notice hot date doesn't matter,
hungry doesn't matter and rainy doesn't matter. And the only thing that matters
are whether you're occupied, what type
of restaurant you're at and whether you're
happy or not. Or whether the, the patrons in the restaurants are restaurant is,
are happy or not. But, here's the other thing
about this. It's not just about the features. Let's tie
it back in to the other things, that we
mentioned in the beginning. This, in our case, this table
actually represents our testing set. It's the thing that
we're going to look at to determine whether we were
right or wrong. These are the examples that we're going to
do to see whether we generalize or not. And this
particular tree here is our candidate concept. So there's lots
and lots and lots of other trees that we might
have used. We might have used a tree that also
took, asked questions about whether it was rainy or not
or asked questions about whether you were on a hot
date or not. But we didn't. We picked a specific
tree that had only these three features and only asked
in this particular way. So what we're going to talk about next.
Is how we might decide whether to choose this tree over any
of the other possible number of trees that we might have chosen instead.